Speaker 1: Hey, I want to call your attention
to something maybe you forgot about.
Does everybody remember when a few months
ago the corporate media decided that now we
have to talk about the lab leak theory of
covid and we all have to say, hey, could it
have been made in a Chinese laboratory as
a bioweapon?
Could it accidentally have leaked from the
lab?
And of course, some of us like me had all
along been saying the exact same thing, investigate
everything.
Why would we, without investigating, say something
is true or isn't true?
Let's let's investigate the origins of covid.
But until we have evidence that it came from
a lab or was deliberately made and released
as a bioweapon, until we have evidence for
that, it would be irresponsible to suggest
that that is likely.
And that's what I said in twenty twenty and
that's what I said in early twenty, twenty
one.
And it's what I said a few months ago when
the story was raging.
But for some reason a few months ago, the
story was everywhere in the media and it was
framed as why are some like Dr. Foushee and
the Left, whoever?
Why are people covering up and preventing
an investigation into the lab leak theory?
Now, the reality was just about everybody
was saying, sure, investigated.
Look into it, but we just don't have evidence
right now that that's actually what took place.
But the cover up hypothesis is prototypical
of how you generate more media interest.
You not only float an idea, but you claim
that the idea is being suppressed, that the
idea is being covered up.
And this actually worked because a couple
of months ago, members of the media actually
started asking Joe Biden and Biden administration
officials about it.
They would ask Jen Psaki in the press briefing
room.
Jen, does the Biden administration oppose
investigating what the origins?
No, no, it doesn't oppose.
We're fine with an investigation.
I think it was Peter Steve Doocy, Peter Doocy,
who asked Joe Biden about it, and Joe Biden
said investigate, go ahead and investigate.
And just about everybody was saying, we don't
rule out anything.
Let's find out.
But we don't yet have evidence that that's
the case.
Now, here's the really important part in understanding
these media cycles.
When this bubbled up a couple of months ago
and Joe Biden was asked about it and so was
Jen Psaki, there was no new evidence at that
time that would make us say this now looks
much more likely.
So let's ask about it.
It came in and then it suddenly went away
and it became a nonstory.
It may come back again.
At no point was there really any reason to
think that covid was a bioweapon that came
from a lab.
It's just the perfect prototypical example
of how something becomes a story in the media.
And then just as quickly the story goes away
and we don't even really understand why.
And this was the case all along.
And then very quietly, a few days ago, we
got a new report published written about in
Nature which explains that, quote, The intelligence
investigation is inconclusive on virus's origins,
but finds it wasn't weaponized and it is unlikely
to have been engineered, according to the
declassified key takeaways issued by the Office
of the Director of National Intelligence and
the intelligence community.
More broadly, it's been assessed that the
covid virus likely first appeared in Wuhan
no later than November of twenty nineteen,
emerged without the knowledge of Chinese authorities
and was not developed as a bioweapon.
Most agencies also agreed, though with low
confidence, that it was probably not genetically
engineered, although to an agency's believe
we don't yet have enough evidence to say for
sure.
So when you read it, if you read it with the
conspiratorial mind, you say this is part
of the cover up.
There's sort of not closing the door completely
to the possibility.
But but if you actually look at it for what
it is, understand that for a very long time
there was fear, uncertainty and doubt generated
around the idea that the true origins were
being covered up.
The truth is, we never had evidence to believe
that this was bioengineered or leaked from
a lab or released as a bioweapon.
We didn't have evidence for that.
We couldn't rule it out.
Sometimes in science, you can't rule things
out, but you don't have evidence for them
that allowed for people to weaponize the hypothesis,
to attack others, to claim that there were
bad liberal people lying and covering this
up.
And I am still open to the possibility that
this was being studied and it leaked or whatever.
I don't think we should put any kind of limitation
on studying it, but we don't have evidence
for it.
And it's very similar to the use of the migrant
caravanned stories or stories of Middle Eastern
terrorists coming through the US Mexico border.
All these things are physically possible.
They're theoretically possible someone could
go from the Middle East to Guatemala and then
come to Mexico and physically cross the US
Mexico border.
We don't actually have evidence that that's
going on.
And there's this churn of unverifiable, rage
inducing propaganda.
There are legitimate questions about the exact
chemistry of the Wuhan's strains and about
events at the Wuhan lab.
It's been discussed in reputable media.
Let's investigate it.
There is no reason right now to think that
it came from a lab just like before.
So how much are we going to sort of repeat
the same story absent that evidence?
Now, one other thing.
There's another important thing.
When people say this is being discussed everywhere
online, like how is this not a serious story?
The discussion online is biased towards controversy
and conspiracy.
You just have to understand that.
And that's important when we talk about the
baseline of a lot of these discussions.
But the perfect example, the story came two
months ago and then it went.
And we still don't have more evidence that
any of those hypotheses are true